hoping to get a win tonight as kyle
hendricks
is on the mound right-hander wrapping up
his warm-up tosses
that one lifted in the air softly hit
out towards right field making the call
in the grab is alcantara but he slugs
over 500 so there's power with contact
that one drilled to right but right now
jason hayward
and on nine pitches
pal hendricks gets him one two three end
of a half finning the indians nothing
and then cubs coming back well eli
morgan is going to be the starter making
his third start
there it is good change-up struck him
out one away
swing and a miss he struck him out what
a start by eli morgan rosario riding a
nine-game hit street
got him reaching out to change him that
pitch has
been really good here tonight
to roll over that time that's wisdom on
the right side throws him out maybe he's
saving that for later
[Applause]
that one is drilled out towards left
center but
settling under it is zimmer
he's got it
[Music]
that ball is lined and caught at third
[Applause]
morgan delivering
their strength three
moved it a little bit closer to the
outside corner and murris nick's out
looking and a good start for eli morgan
here's the wind-up and the pitch and
lavard way with a rocket to left center
this ball is going to hit the base of
the wall
and he is on his way to second base with
a stand-up double his first extra base
hit as an indian
he
provide that for people is just
incredible jason with the catch in right
steals a hit from zimmer
and then the throw back in a bullet to
right field well the one constant you
can always expect out of jason hayward
superb defense good sliding play pops up
holds that runner to second base
and he chased that one a strikeout
hendricks needed that
3-2
[Music]
and there got him looking pendrick's
rings up hernandez class of kool-aid
right now with a cupcake
the pitch swung on and missed got him
with another change up eli morgan's
fourth
the pitch
and it's straight three called hendricks
out looking
[Applause]
that one line hendricks couldn't find it
see if he's all right
he waved off the trainer said it got him
in the glove
swing and a miss right there bradley
down on strikes and kyle
picks up his fourth punt shot
and a swing and a miss and eli morgan
has gotten the first 10-6
on strikeouts
nothing nothing game bottom of the
fourth here's chris bryant
kyle is 12 out of 14. next roll center
field zimmer
well that's got to feel good for chris
bryant the home run is 14th
one nothing comes
oh what a pretty swing
he didn't miss that one got a pitch he
could handle out over the plate
absolutely crushes it
just left to center field
somebody out in the bleach is going home
with a souvenir and the whole entire
bench is saying yes yes yes
write it down in the storybook i think
somebody did
check swing but he went struck him out
and kyle deals
got a curveball hit into right field
that's a base hit
so naylor stayed back and
knocking a man aboard
rather than down short
and have guys reach out and be able to
just hit a lazy fly ball breaking ball
swing and a miss he pitches around the
lead off single five a shutout
in the air to center coming on is zimmer
and he's got it there two outs
but it's also too late
if that guy does what he does on the
mount it has something on him
[Applause]
nice catch
is there another avenue i can go to get
him out
on the ground to the bay's head he just
got enough of that changeup
and hernandez with a single to lead it
off
on the ground
[Music]
in the year out towards left center jack
started in now back it over
in the air left field where sario gets
turned around over his head
[Applause]
they're going to stop him they slip down
a throw
off line
and they're at the corners with nobody
out as ortega comes through with a knock
lined a left center that's a base hit
that'll score one ortega speeding around
the bases around third they're gonna
send him out his way to the plate and
check
knocks in two
crooked number
freeze it
different things throughout the game
that's outside and a good and back from
k.b
still nobody out
to two
brush down the left side
tops off the side wall towards the
corner
and a fan touched it
so baez into second end to score is jack
peterson bryant will stop at
third and it is four nothing
stepp was back that one ladies ahead
brian in the hold up bias contreras
headed to second and he'll make it
[Applause]
have a very good year out of the bullpen
in the 30 innings see that 170 80 r.a
[Applause]
little roller to first
kb champion nice footwork by the sheriff
the focus of the whole bullpen he's just
been so impressed with
the bullpen has been sensational those
three guys have been
a monster part of it
and ernie clement
swings and lines one up the middle base
hit center field
look at that
a four-pitch walk
and the bases are loaded
bouncing over the middle
and
bias steps on second they get the force
there the indians get a run home
they get the first out of the inning
zimmer scoring on the play claumette
goes to third
payoff pitch
mauriznick is there and he gets out of
it well done ryan tapara there's wilson
contreras one for
[Applause]
back near three wall
a basketball for wilson contreras he'll
touch them all
6-1
and with that home run
frank campbell has
sat down this one charged now
back to back
wilson then wisdom
and for patrick it's number 10.
ryan lavarnway pops it up foul right
side down the line bryant is there he's
got it and the cubs win the ball game